what would happen
if our planet got too close to a black
hole
well according to science fiction we'd
be sucked into a parallel universe
or maybe even the future
but in reality it wouldn't be nearly
that fun
instead our planet would be ripped apart
piece by piece starting with our
atmosphere
so what if we moved a little further
back
instead of the black hole being right
beside us
we move it to the center of our solar
system
would our planet still be destroyed
and what would that do to our solar
system
as a whole this is what if
and here's what would happen if the
solar system
orbited a black hole
this black hole has the same mass as our
sun
if we were to place it next to our sun
the two objects would orbit each other
at a close distance about one-tenth the
distance between earth and the sun
this would mean that our solar system
was now orbiting
a local point with twice the mass of the
sun
as a result the planets would have to
orbit faster
to avoid getting pulled inwards a year
on earth
would decrease from 365 days
to 258 days and
the amount of energy from the sun would
vary as it orbited closer to and
farther away from earth other than that
life would pretty well be the same but
what if we replaced our sun with a black
hole completely
well we'd have a lot more to worry about
than just the length of a year
which by the way would be over in the
blink of an eye
[Music]
the biggest problem we would face if we
replace the sun with a black hole
would be the absence of incoming solar
energy
the planet earth would go completely
dark
thanks to our planet's infamous
greenhouse gas effect
the global temperature wouldn't be
reduced instantaneously
but after the first week earth's average
surface temperature
would drop to zero degrees and then
to negative 101 degrees by the end of
the first year
you'd think that our planet quickly
becoming an ice world would be
bad enough but we're just getting
started
without sunlight there would be no
photosynthesis
the process by which all plants generate
food
small plants would die in a matter of
days
this would create a ripple effect
throughout the entire food chain
causing us all to starve to death
eventually
but maybe there is a way we can get
usable
energy from a black hole and it all
starts with something called
cmb
cmb also known as cosmic microwave
background
is the weak radiation left over from the
big bang
theoretically if a black hole spins fast
enough
it can compress the cmb radiation into
optical wavelengths the same wavelengths
that are emitted by the sun
the wavelengths would funnel into a
narrow beam and
before you know it our planet would have
usable energy once again
alright but there is a small catch
the faster rotation of the black hole
would also
pull the planetary orbits in closer to
the point of no escape
for the planetary orbits to remain
stable and
avoid being sucked up the orbital
velocity of the planets
would need to be close to the speed of
light this means that
a year on earth would be over before the
blink of an eye
so much for your big new year's eve
party
but there's no time to worry about that
because we've got
bigger issues coming our way
if any material like meteors satellites
or space debris
gets sucked into the black hole it will
result in a
blast of radiation coming our way and
when the radiation arrives at our planet
it will
blow away our atmosphere killing
anything in its path
so even though the sun can be annoying
sometimes
when it comes to things to orbit around
we could do a lot worse the next time
you look up at a sunny sky
don't take it for granted it will
disappear one day
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]